thank you just got said ago - by members
of the support group from The Fault in
Our Stars movie I've been on set for the
movie for the last couple weeks in very
little news like penetrates the bubble
of the movie so I want to thank you for
your video about the government shutdown
which I previously didn't understand at
all and now understand only in the sense
that I'm like are you serious that
really anyway great video so earlier
this week I got to ask Ansel Elgort who
plays it bestest waters in the movie
some real questions from real
nerdfighters you ready hold on I gotta
use my thumbprint
oh don't touch don't touch it's not for
it's not for regular people like for
specials what's it like working with a
brilliant author like John Green you
know what I thought it would be better I
was expecting much more there's a lot of
people asking if what they call Jon soul
is gonna be a thing yeah I think it's
already I think it's a thing it's a
thing I ship it
yeah my wife who's here on set was like
on Twitter you're acting like you have a
crush on Ansel and I was like cuz I do
acting what was your favorite scene to
film in the movie so far
Friday night we did the scene in the car
we're Gus don't exactly give no spoilers
that's perfect I think people will know
what that refers to but people who
haven't read the book won't be spoiled
that's Brooke that was your favorite
yeah it was pretty that was I think
that's my favorite scene ever done as an
actor so tell me the story of how you
found out that you've gotten the part I
was in Chicago not shooting a virgin and
on divergent me and Shay had become
friends and I was going to New York City
for the weekend she gave me a package so
do not open this package whatever you do
I said why not I said just don't open it
I got on the airplane everything
whatever go home
four days pass still can't open a
package
then I got a call from Josh Boone he
says pants the trailing give you a
package and I say yeah I said open up
the package so I opened up the package
was really hard to open until I covered
in tape was very secure package and
inside was a rotten Dutch cheese and
tomato sandwich I said we're going
Amsterdam and that's how many I got
oh my goodness is that not the cutest
thing you've ever heard also Alan said I
got to interview Mike Birbiglia one of
my favorite comedian slash people who
plays Patrick in the movie what
attracted me the movie was the book
originally is the book well I'll tell
you the exact sequence of events and
then we can make up turn diversion for
this basically Birbiglia love the
spectacular now became friends with the
screenwriters who recommended the fall
nurse sorry whatever the story we made
up is much better here's the version of
the story that might be better frequent
television you read I read the book it
was so especially Matt wrote me will let
I mean that a letter a letter is a
letter letter and it was the longhand
like in the Middle Ages yeah it was on
the scroll yeah and and you said where
is this weird scroll host dream to find
a book but I saw this guy's movie yeah
he's pretty funny right and he should
play Augustus yes and then the studio is
like he's a little old mm-hmm yeah yeah
so so they're like oh yeah they were
wrong yeah yeah do do songs it's so
sweet
we're not the grammar error yeah no
worse dogs I've ever had prompt me that
you're getting well I would yeah good
good interview ain't clearly I missed my
calling I should have been a
professional interviewer anyway I'll see
you on Friday
no it is Friday I'll see you on Tuesday
what I why didn't we switch up it's
making everything weird if the
government hadn't shut down none of this
would've happened it would have been me
Tuesday Hank Friday me - now who even
knows anymore I'll see you at some
indeterminate point in the future thanks
government